bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette édition
du 13 novembre du journal de la
rédaction 18 heures si vous nous suivez
en direct et dans l'actualité locale la
mission rosetta a permis aux robots
villa et de se poser sur la comète
chori un événement suivi jusque dans les
locaux de l'observatoire de versailles
50 ans l'établissement situé à
guyancourt qui a pris une part active
dans ce succès retransmettait donc
l'événement et hier soir nous irons en
mémoire de la grande guerre de 14 18 les
commémorations se poursuivent nous
ouvrirons aussi ce soir une large page
dédiée aux événements dans notre secteur
des yvelines jean luc roux adjoint au
maire de montigny le bretonneux nous
expliquera pourquoi sa ville a reçu le
label décerné par l'office nationale des
combattants elles ne sont que 12 dans
les yvelines et puis également en
plateau romain dugast des archives
départementales pour évoquer entre
autres le travail de collecte menée
actuellement le syndicat alliance police
nationale appelée aujourd'hui tous les
policiers à se réunir place de la
bastille à paris pour revendiquer leur
mécontentement face à la mutualisation
des services les fonctionnaires du
département des yvelines très impactées
par cette réforme
à peine un geste fort de la part de
l'administration sur la ddsp 78 on s'est
passé cette année sur le budget 2014 de
plus de 20 véhicules ce qui est colossal
aujourd'hui on a des bâtiments que les
collègues ne peuvent pas utiliser parce
qu'ils sont en cours de rénovation
on a les collègues du ce qu'on appelle
le s diane le service de nuit qui ont
déménagé leurs affaires personnelles
avec leur véhicule personnel et un
évidemment si on veut des coups des
policiers motivé sur le terrain et qu'on
arrête de stigmatiser et bien il faut au
moins à minima préserver les moyens
budgétaires financiers ce soit pour bien
évidemment les salaires des
fonctionnaires mais aussi pour leur
permettre de travailler et aussi pour
les moyens de protection et tous les
policiers n'étaient pas en grève
aujourd'hui cet après midi à guyancourt
à montigny le bretonneux à une série de
contrôles routiers opérations sous le
signe de la prévention une hausse des
accidents ont été constatés dans les
yvelines ces derniers mois 15 policiers
et des péchés donc sur place pour
procéder à des vérifications papier ou
encore des contrôles d'alcoolémie
les fouilles de véhicules ont également
pu être effectués cas de nécessité bien
évidemment le robot fil à aiguille a
bien atterri sur la comète souris dix
ans de voyages cette heure de chutes
depuis la sonde rosetta soulagement pour
la communauté spatiale européenne
l'observatoire de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines responsable de
l'installation de plusieurs instruments
a ouvert ses portes au public pour
retransmettre en direct cet événement
historique
hier soir reportage mélanie poquet et le
dit - enfin fila et ses positions depuis
20 ans qu'il attend de la mission est
approuvée par le comité de programme
scientifique de l'esa en 1993 mais
rosetta n'est lancé que le 2 mars 2004
ici à guyancourt
cet atterrissage et marquant le premier
sentiment c'est l'émotion de voir
une entreprise qui était singulière et
qui était la première de ce type là
réussir une récompense des gens qui ont
travaillé très très longtemps et qu'il a
à voir voile fruits se réaliser dans
leurs efforts et puis et puis donc voilà
mis en lumière le travail des gens sur
cette mission qui est qui est
emblématique le latmos laboratoire
atmosphères milieux observations
spatiales a participé à l'élaboration de
cette des 20 instruments présents à bord
de rosetta et fila et et notamment
concert un sondeur présent sur
l'orbiteur et sur le robot c'est un
travail international donc toutes les
données seront échangées entre les gens
qui sont impliqués
l'enjeu pour nous c'est de comprendre
comment s'est constituée une comète
et après quels sont les gaz qui
s'échappent de cette comète et qui la
composent pour effectivement comprendre
qu'elle a pu être le rôle de ces objets
l'atterrissage n'a pas été parfait fil à
et a finalement rebondi pour atterrir à
1 km de sa cible
hélas pas réussi à déclencher ses harpon
il se trouverait sur une pente fortement
incliné le manque d'ensoleillement
pourrait aussi écourté son
fonctionnement
mais pour le moment le robot fonctionne
bien l aventure doit se conclure le 31
décembre 2015
quatre ans trois mois et deux semaines
c'est la durée de ce conflit connu sous
le nom de grande guerre la triple
entente face à la triple alliance france
empire britannique empire russe
notamment face aux empires allemand
autres on voit encore ottoman les
commémorations du centenaire débute tout
juste elles s'achèveront en 2018 à cette
occasion nous allons parler ce soir de
la mobilisation des communes et du
département deux invités en plateau dans
un instant mais tout d'abord un micro
trottoir
que savez vous de ce conflit de 14-18
comment l'histoire vous a été transmise
vos réponses chaque 11 novembre on
allait tout l'école toute la journée
pratiquement au monument aux morts on
listel et non et on venait chacun avec
notre propre bouquet de fleurs et ont
déposé les fleurs toutes les veuves
habillés en noir était là nous
nous regardait faire c'était très très
émouvant le grand père je le rappelle
qui me pousse disait ben dans les
tranchées il a été dans les tranchées en
les pieds dans l'eau et puis tu voyais
nous expliquer tout un tas de toutes ces
histoires
ces importantes pour lui qu'il avait
traumatisé apparemment mon grand père il
est mort à saint quentin
c'était un musicien et donc est là et il
le joue de la trompette la fin de la
guerre et là malheureusement à la fin
ils ont lancé encore une bombe et gace
et les mohawks le dernier jour avec ce
micro trottoir nous ouvrons une page
donc dédié à 14 18 dans ce journal deux
invités en plateau romand dugast tout
d'abord bonsoir vous êtes le chef des
archives des services publics et
services au public aux archives
départementales des yvelines et puis
jean luc rigaut bonsoir mâcha deuxième
adjoint au maire de montigny le
bretonneux votre ville qui a reçu la
labellisation délivré par l'office
national des anciens combattants
il n'y a que douze communes dans le
département des yvelines avoir reçu ce
label doit tout d'abord revenir avec
vous sur la commémoration du 11 novembre
il ya quelques jours dans votre commune
à montigny-le-bretonneux mille personnes
présentes on va revoir les images et
puis 250 enfants pour chanter la
marseillaise est véritablement ressentir
ce fort moment d'émotion c'était inédit
à montigny-le-bretonneux d'une telle
ampleur c'est une grande première
effectivement et on a été ravi de voir 2
100 des 150 enfants 240 250 accompagnés
de leurs parents grands parents souvent
pour cette commémoration qui la première
depuis
moi j'habite sur monthey défie 30 ans je
n'ai jamais vu une telle commémoration
qui est sur la même enthousiasme
beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup d'émotion
internes que nous avons vécu y compris
avec tous les tous les membres de nos
villes jumelles qui était présent mais
je pense qu'on va y revenir un petit peu
mais c'était vraiment une grande émotion
y compris des membres de lui lancer des
anciens combattants qui étaient là
certes plus de la grande guerre mais en
tout cas pour certains d'entre eux de la
guerre 40
justement on aurait pu penser qu'avec la
disparition des derniers combattants des
poilus finalement ces commémorations
tombent petit à petit dans l'oubli ce
n'est pas le cas à ce que vous avez
sentiment tous les deux peut-être aux
archives le public vient vous voir et
veut connaître l'histoire on constate
effectivement qu'il ya un engouement
très fort de la participation du public
à 7 à ces célébrations
on a pu constater l'année dernière avec
les grandes collectes qui avait été
lancée en 2013 et qui est reconduite
cette année et qui fonctionne très bien
auprès du public très large
collecte dont on va parler aussi de dans
un instant puisqu'elle a lieu en ce
moment une nouvelle vague de collecte
des différents documents auprès et du
public yvelinois vous le ressentez aussi
cet engouement alors gelé toute une
série de manifestations organisées sur
la ville il n'y a pas que c est quand
même rassurant non vie a prévu que cette
commémoration puisque nous avons fait un
pèlerinage dans la somme un pèlerinage
organisé par notre association de
jumelage et sous la grande direction de
madame claudine la droit et de son mari
mais de ma collègue élu michel parent et
marité attendrait donc voilà c'est on a
emmené un bus complet sur les sur les
champs de bataille de la somme dans les
cimetières dans l'est dans les musées ça
a été la première manifestation
extérieure dont vous voyez qu'on est
sortis simplement entre guillemets du
cadre du département des yvelines pour
aller voir sur le terrain qu'est ce qui
s'est passé là-bas à l'époque toute une
série de manifestations qui sont
organisées depuis le début de la semaine
à montigny le bretonneux un village dans
la grande guerre c'est le nom d'une
exposition aussi à découvrir jusqu'à ce
week end à montigny-le-bretonneux
exposition le documentaire nous sommes
allés la découvrir le reportage de
catherine château pas moins de 300
objets collectés répertoriés et
commenter la grande guerre n'est par une
dans les yvelines mais des soldats sont
partis au front et ce sont ses souvenirs
militaires comme personnel
qui sont exposées des armes il y en a
énormément et des armes rares dont un
fusil anglais des médailles aussi parce
qu'il ya des médailles aussi bien
étrangère que française
et aussi il ya des jets trier sont les
choses très très rare qui sont les
étriers de cavalerie qui ont la
particularité de s'ouvrir pour pas que
le cavalier reste accroché à la scène
parmi les armes présenter ce fusil
lourdes 4 kg 5
le fusil là ils étaient a été mis en
service en 1907
l'italie elle field numéro un il a été
fabriqué en dix sept versions
différentes
c'était bon travail honnête c'est une
brique longue qui celui ci lui calibre
303 je fus ville a été utilisée jusqu'en
1941 des pièces plus personnel sont
également proposés des lettres de poilus
des cartes postales des journaux de bord
écrit chaque jour pour mieux comprendre
l'enfer de la grande guerre il ya des
objets personnels oui il ya des petites
miniatures de plomb moi j'ai des mails
de monts
de mon père qui était né en 1900 qui a
fait les deux guerres donc j'essaie
décoration ça c'est personnel
l'exposition a pu voir le jour grâce au
travail mené par le club des
collectionneurs des yvelines elle est
présentée au siège de l'ufc dans les
locaux de l'ancienne mairie une seconde
partie de l'exposition est visible à
l'hôtel de ville jusqu'au 15 novembre
la commune de montigny le bretonneux
fait partie des douze villes des
yvelines avoir obtenu la labellisation
délivré par l'office national des
anciens combattants de retour en plateau
donc pour évoquer la grande guerre dans
les yvelines à montigny le bretonneux
tout d'abord en particulier avec cette
exposition entendus à la fin du sujet je
le disais si tout à l'heure il ya cette
labellisation par les anciens
combattants et que douze villes dans le
département ça ça représente quoi
oui alors ça c'est un dossier que j'ai
personnellement mené bien sûr à la
demande de monsieur le maire nous avons
absolument voulu donner une certaine
ampleur certaine dimension à cette
commémoration du centenaire de la grande
guerre et pour nous c'était important
d'avoir le label parce que cela nous a
permis bien sûr de profiter de
l'expérience de l'office national des
anciens combattants
mais je dirais d'accéder à des tas de
documents et je fais je remercie aussi
les archives départementales parce qu'il
ya un très très gros travail de fait
avec les archives mais surtout je crois
qu'on a donné une dimension à laquelle
nous mêmes on était un peu surpris 1
pour être honnête parce que nous avions
dans notre projet la participation de
deux villes jumelles denton en
angleterre et kirsten allemagne et
c'était déjà quelque chose d'arriver à
motiver nos amis allemands pour
participer je crois que ce qui a
intéressé l'office national des anciens
combattants
c'est que l'exposition qui est
aujourd'hui à montigny une partie va
aller en angleterre et ensuite elle va
se retrouver en allemagne à toute
l'exposition parce qu'elle est tellement
énorme
et donc voilà c'est cette dimension
européenne que l'office nationale des
combattants a retenu alors effectivement
il ya beaucoup de souvenirs personnels
en voilà un c'est une lettre de poilu
c'est aussi personnelle c'est celle de
mon grand-père a malheureusement été
tués donc on a vu sortir de parmi les
inimitables beaucoup beaucoup de
documents personnels qui avait pas eu
cette mobilisation autour du centenaire
je pense rester dans l'église dans les
cartons cette lecture vous avez évoqué
qui a été écrite justement vous dire par
votre grand-angle rentrons que c'était
juste avant son décès en 1914 c'était
juste avant son décès il a été transmis
commandera passé voilà s'est transmis de
génération en génération et mon père a
conservé tous étaient tous ces documents
et à la sagesse à la salle jacques brel
on a eu une projection du film joyeux
noël mais préalablement on a eu des
lectures de ceux de ce type de lettre
des lectures théâtralisées par des
jeunes et ça ça a été un moment très
très très important où notre député de
denton qui était présent lui même a été
absolument sidéré de voir que on avait
mis toute cette cette énergie à bâtir ce
projet autour du centenaire et à la
salle jacques-brel ya de ça trois jours
l'émotion était très forte
il ya une collecte actuellement qui est
organisé au niveau du département des
yvelines 262 communes du département qui
se mobilisent pour retrouver des
archives que chacun vous un petit peu
donc dans son grenier dans ses caves
pour trouver des documents qui sont très
précieux regarde de l'histoire comment
se passe la collecte qui vient de
débuter aujourd'hui voilà en fait la
collecte est organisée à l'échelle
nationale principalement sur la date du
14 au 15 novembre
nous avons souhaité proposer
une amplitude plus large en commençant
la collecte à partir du 12 donc elle a
commencé mercredi sa commencent plus
doucement que l'année dernière parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a eu un affluent du
fait de la nouveauté aussi les gens
s'étaient précipités pour nous apporter
des documents
on a un peu moins de contributeurs cette
année pour le moment en tout cas
donc j'invite toutes les personnes qui
vont encore des choses à bien sûr nous
les apporter pour qu'elles soient
numérisés ont leur restituer les
documents ou si elle souhaite nous les
données peuvent aussi le faire mais on a
déjà des choses très intéressantes
aujourd'hui nous avons reçu notamment un
journal qui était dite et mensuellement
par un prisonnier français dans un camp
en allemagne un journal illustré où il y
avait des dessins de deux sons de sa
cellule dans un enfermement etc
nous avons reçu un sabre nous avons reçu
une canne sculptée avec les mentions de
la bataille de verdun dessus donc il ya
vraiment des choses anecdotiques et très
intéressante qui témoignent de la
diversité je dirais de l'histoire
personnelle des familles qui subsistent
et c'est toujours un plaisir
d'accueillir ces différents témoignages
et les gens sont souvent désireux
justement de le transmettre cette
mémoire en le faisant numérisés en
sauvant parfois des documents dont
l'encré commence à s'effacer
c'est un moyen aussi de deux d'inscrire
dans le temps je dirais ce témoignage
donc c'est important et c'est
intéressant donc j'invite encore tous
les gens qui veulent y participer
jusqu'à samedi jusqu'à samedi
ils peuvent le faire en venant aux
archives ou dans les cinq communes des
yvelines qui participe encore cette
année je n'ai pas encore je n'ai pas en
mémoire le nom des participants mais je
sais qu'il ya la celle-saint-cloud par
exemple vélizy villacoublay
voilà il ya d'autres communes qui
participent dans les yvelines mais le
plus simple cette source était pas
tellement table pour avoir toutes les
informations qui sont qui sont
nécessaires les documents qui sont
collectés permettent d'en savoir plus
aussi sur la façon dont ça s'est déroulé
dans le département des yvelines parce
que vous évoquez tous ces documents ils
viennent de partout ils viennent de
toute la france
pas nécessairement des dialogues on
parlait de montigné à l'époque montini
c'était 200 300 habitants en continu
c'était 200 220 habitants
exactement et il ya eu toute cette
recherche fed fait d'ailleurs par les
élèves du lycée descartes de la première
qui ont pris tous les noms figurant sur
le monument aux morts de montigny et
avec donc madame adroit qui ont fait des
recherches sur le monument au moins et
c'est comme ça qu'on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait sur le monument aux morts
des gens qui n'étaient pas de montigny
c'était tout simplement des travailleurs
de la ferme du manet mais qui ont été
tuées malheureusement pendant la grande
guerre et leurs familles ont demandé à
ceux qui figurent sur le monde nombre de
montigny voilà un exemple donc ça permet
d'en savoir plus sur le département
directement la guerre s'est passé ici
la collecte est un aspect des choses
parce qu'effectivement on n'exclut
personne pour cette collecte que les
documents concernent directement les
yvelines où d'autres régions on numérise
un peu tout tout sera visible sur notre
site internet
une partie une petite sélection figurera
sur la plateforme nationale de la
collecte
et puis je sais pas si on en parlera
après mais on a d'autres projets allez-y
justement parce qu'il ya un jeu qui se
met en place également identification
des poilus yvelinois y un wiki voilà
tout à fait collaborative exactement
donc la collecte permet aussi de comme
vous le disiez d'avoir une meilleure
connaissance du conflit dans un
territoire de l'ariège qui était
l'ancien cinéma à l'époque et nous avons
lancé c'est actuellement disponibles sur
internet une plateforme collaborative de
type wikipedia dédié à l'histoire de la
grande guerre dans les yvelines
donc concrètement qu'est ce que c'est
tout à chacun peut en se connectant
contribuer à apporter une part de
connaissances sur cette histoire
en rédigeant un article donc le plus
simple ça peut être justement de
retracer l'histoire de son ancêtre
puisque aux archives départementales
vous le savez peut-être sont conservés
les fiches matricule
c'est à dire le recensement militaire
des jeunes gens de 20 ans qui est tout
leur parcours militaire pendant la
guerre donc à partir de cette fiche
matricule on peut l'étoffé lui donner du
corps à ce document administratif en
joignant une photo
donc voilà ce qui est collecté permet
aussi d'étoffer les documents
administratifs et public conservés aux
archives départementales et je voudrais
ajouter un point c'est qu'effectivement
lors de du 11 novembre le président de
la république a inauguré
le portail national le grand mémorial
qui est en fait un portail unique qui
donnera accès à l'ensemble des fiches
matricule et donc on aura accès aux 750
mille soldats de la grande guerre où
qu'ils soient
c'est à dire sans avoir à connaître le
lieu de recrutement puisque dire que si
vous passez par ce portail ça renvoie
directement en tapant le nom de
l'individu
vous êtes renvoyé par exemple aux
archives départementales des yvelines
puisque tous chez nous et numérisé et
indexé
80e c'est quelque chose qui sont
organisés autour ces commémorations dans
le département que ce soit dans les
communes que ce soit par les archives
départementales il ya aussi notamment
ces ateliers qui sont mis en place un
atelier généalogie entre autres qui se
déroule jusqu'à vendredi nous avons
assisté à l'une des séances sortir de
l'oubli un combattant de la grande
guerre un grand père ou un
arrière-grand-père voilà ce que propose
l'atelier généalogie organisé aux
archives départementales
vous savez on a souvent des souvenirs de
famille des histoires des anecdotes
véhiculée par la mémoire familiale mais
on a rarement les documents qui viennent
à l'appui des anecdotes qui nous ont été
transmises au fil des générations
il y a beaucoup d'émotion même dans le
cadre de ses recherches qui font revivre
bien sûr des ddd mort qui pourrait
rester anonyme mais qui sont des membres
de la famille qui sont des membres d'une
collectivité
l'atelier s'adresse à tous généalogistes
et inconditionnel ou débutants les
techniques étant grandement simplifié
par informatique
j'ai la conviction que cet atelier
s'adresse à tout le monde bien entendu
il y à des techniques de recherche qui
sont répandues dans la communauté
généalogique
mais aujourd'hui les outils sont à
portée de clic l'état civil à son rôle
puisque il faut quand même connaître
l'âge
des personnages sur lesquels on
travaille pour par exemple trouver le
document essentiel le la fiche matricule
l'état signalétique et des services qui
est le document de base qui va nous
permettre de reconstituer le parcours de
notre ancêtre
chacun a ses raisons de participer à cet
atelier pour certains il s'agit d'un
intérêt historique pour d'autres
compléter l'arbre généalogique de leur
famille
j'ai un grand oncle qui donc est parti à
la guerre 14 18 qui était je pense dans
l'acte yves et qui partit avec les
l'armée d'orient
j'ai perdu la trace à salonique
il a été malade il a été transporté dans
un hôpital de campagne
et puis après je n'ai plus rien donc à
voir ici comment faire comment
s'organiser pierre la durée membres
d'une société historique et
archéologique est basée à marly-le-roi
et dont le grand père était médecin aux
armées savoir effectivement le chemin
qui l'a fait comment il est parti de sa
faculté de médecine jusqu'à parce que
lui nous nous en a pas parlé du tout
voilà donc le découvrir sur un autre
jour ces ateliers sont proposés jusqu'à
vendredi atelier jusqu'à vendredi il est
encore possible de s'y inscrire oui des
succès dans la 2 ateliers encore
vendredi un à 14h de mémoire et l'autre
à 17h30 je pense que celui de 17h30 et
complet mais il reste encore de la place
pour celui de 14h aura les pieds de
toutes les animations qui sont proposées
soient retrouvés sur le site internet
des archives pour découvrir les images
déjà de l'exposition revenir sur les
commémorations et l site internet de la
ville de montigny est également juste un
dernier mot le conseil général des
yvelines va aussi lancer en décembre à
un jeu internet autour de tout ça tout à
fait ce qu'on appelle un serious game
donc un jeu sérieux qui sera un jeu
pédagogique qui permettra d'acquérir la
connaissance de recherches sur cette
période de 14-18 donc ça se présentera
sous la forme d'un jeu concours dans un
premier temps à partir de la première
semaine de décembre
une énigme par semaine et l'idée c'est à
travers un scénario et au gré des
énigmes de retrouver un mystérieux
polluent donc il ya de nombreux lots à
gagner et notamment un lot dédié aux
collégiens
yvelinois donc j'invite tout le monde
dès à présent à consulter la bande
annonce sur internet et à se préinscrire
pour être avertis du début du concours
là aujourd'hui beaucoup d'animations à
ce que ça va se poursuivre jusqu'en 2018
que soit mon pti niveau aux archives
mais sur sur montigny oui nous allons
accompagner pendant les quatre ans à
venir
toute cette commémoration autour du
centenaire
on a surtout et je le voyais en corse
d'après midi à l'hôtel de ville des
classes des classes de jeunes qui
viennent
et là ils ont été pris en photo avec les
deux poilus qui pour la circonstance
sont en uniforme d'époque
c'est vraiment très très important que
cette mémoire soient transmises y
compris pour les beaucoup plus jeunes
que nous car c'est quand même dans le
passé qu'on puisse qu'on puise ses
racines
donc voilà on va on va continuer chaque
année jusqu'en jusqu'en 2018 à célébrer
dignement cette centenaire beaucoup de
choses positives le jeu sera de toute
façon ouvert jusqu'en 2018 la plateforme
est ouverte et une prévu un colloque
international sur les traités de paix en
2018 également il y aura d'autres choses
mais voilà pour les vengeurs inscrits
sur l'avenir si pour en parler merci à
tous les deux évidemment cette page
consacrée pour provisoirement bien sûr
consacré à 14 18 dans le cadre de la
semaine étudiante de l'économie sociale
et solidaire des associations invitent
des étudiants de l'université de
versailles saint quentin à découvrir le
principe d'une épicerie solidaire il
vente jusqu'à demain des boissons ou
encore des gâteaux à prix bas le
reportage de mélanie poker et d'élodie
moines également 30 centimes le café ou
le thé un tarif attractif en cette
saison et ce prix si bas
ce sont les étudiants de l'université
saint quentin en yvelines eux mêmes
qu'ils ont décidé avec un vote à l'heure
du repas
nous avons décidé de tenir une épicerie
solidaire ap tempe horaire
à l'université l'objectif c'est de
montrer qu'il ya une forme d une autre
forme d'économie qui est possible on
voit très bien que le ss peut participer
justement au pouvoir d'achat des
étudiants au moment de l'achat les
membres de l'association en profite pour
faire découvrir le but d'une économie
solidaire ouverte depuis hier et jusqu'à
demain illustrative a déjà attiré une
centaine d'étudiants
ça peut m'intéresser dans le sens où par
exemple dans un distributeur
exemple bête dans les gares le café à un
euro
là j'ai une portion de café qui est bien
pour 30 centimes donc oui je peux faire
acheter mon café ici c'est une très très
bonne idée
en plus pour surtout pour les étudiants
parce que avec notre budget assez serré
grâce aux moyens mis en oeuvre par
l'université de nous offrir par exemple
une pause café par exemple avec notre
prix décidées bas c'est quand même très
intéressant avec seulement 16 euros
d'achat l'association récolter 18 euros
l'objectif à terme de cette initiative
que l'épicerie solidaire ouvre ses
portes dans la future maison de
l'étudiant social toujours et toujours à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines quatre tentes ont été
installées aujourd'hui dans le hall du
bâtiment vauban de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin l'initiative de
l'unef le but sensibiliser les
responsables politiques à la question de
l'encadrement des loyers 200 étudiants
qui se sont pris en photo une
quarantaine d' images ont été postées un
objectif c'est d'interpeller les
différents maires sur la question de
l'encadrement des loyers non qui est une
disposition de la loi allure qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas contraignante
c'est hier que les maires ont le libre
choix d'appliquer ou pas cette loi
pour l'instant il ya seulement quelques
villes comme paris et lille qui ont fait
le choix d'appliquer ses doigts
l'encadrement des loyers s'est pas voilà
loin
lubie de lunettes mais c'est vraiment un
besoin des étudiants pour que tout le
monde tous des gens puissent prendre
leur autonomie et voilà tout simplement
pas faire leur vie d'étudiant ce qui par
ailleurs quand on a son propre
appartement et qu'on n'a pas besoin de
se préoccuper du transport c'est
également un atout pour pouvoir réussir
les hommes ça pourra également permettre
plus d'étudiants de réussir à
l'université dans le budget doué d'un
étudiant le loyer c'est à peu près 55 %
en moyenne et donc ça veut dire que la
moitié des as de l'argent des étudiants
par dans le loyer notamment parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de priver une dernière
information avant de se quitter le
secours populaire à trappes lance un
appel à bénévoles pour mener à bien sa
collecte alimentaire des 15 et 16
novembre collecte qui se déroulera dans
un magasin carrefour market à guyancourt
les bénévoles sont attendus de 9 heures
à 18 heures le samedi de 9 heures à 12
heures 30 le dimanche et autre appel à
bénévoles toujours pour le secours
populaire au niveau du département cette
fois ci du 27 novembre jusqu'au 24
décembre les bonnes volontés sont les
bienvenues pour l'opération paquets
cadeaux dans les fnac de chambourcy ou
encore de vélizy je vous retrouve demain
pour la dernière édition de la semaine
du journal de la rédaction nous
reviendrons sur l'essentiel depuis lundi
et puis sur l'actualité du jour
forcément d'ici là sur tv fils vous avez
rendez vous avec le flhoran parfait pour
un nouveau numéro de file echo 18h30
19h30 et 23h très bonne soirée